[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه
360 حيث الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه
[موسيقى]
في المونديال الاخضر السعودي يبدا 90
دقيقه اخيرا نحو الحلم وتونس تودع رغم
الفوز على بطل العالم
داعش يعلن مقتل زعيم ابو الحسن القرشي في
معارك لم يحددها وينصب ابو الحسين القرشي
خلفا له
من ضربه الغواصات الى صفعه اوكس الى
ابتزاز الغاز ماكرون يبدا زياره ترميم
العلاقه مع بيضا
ولدينا ايضا
فنلندا تستفز موسكو بتدريب الاوكرانيين
على حرب الشتاء وفي شوارع كيف حرب مع زائر
قاسم ترصدها العربيه
[موسيقى]
البدايه مع قصه داعش لليوم والزعيم الرابع
لتنظيم داعش الذي لقي مصرعه بحسب كلمه
صوتيه للمتحدث الرسمي باسم التنظيم على
التليجرام ابو عمر المهاجر قال في تسجيل
صوتي ان زعيم التنظيم ابو الحسن الهاشمي
القرشي قتل اثناء المعارك دون ان يذكر
المكان او الزمان او الظروف وبشكل سريع
وفي الاعلان ذاته كشف المتحدث عن اسم
الزعيم الجديد وهو ابو الحسين الحسيني
القرشي ودعي عناصر التنظيم الى مبايعته
اذا انكشفت التنظيم عنه داعيا اعضاءه
لمبايعته في مايو الماضي ترددت انباء عن
القاء القبض على ابو الحسن القرشي واسمه
المعروف هو زيد العراقي خلال عمليه امنيه
نفذت في اسطنبول وتولى ابو الحسن قياده
التنظيم بعد مقتل زعيمه السابق ابو
ابراهيم القرشي بعمليه ام امريكيه على
الاراضي السوريه في الثالث من فبراير
الماضي سبق ذلك مقتل مؤسس التنظيم ابو بكر
البغدادي في اكتوبر من عام 2019 وعرف عن
الزعيم الرابع لداعش ابو الحسن الذي اعلن
عن مقتله اليوم بانه استاذ داعش لتوله
امور التعليم عندما بسط التنظيم سيطرته
على مناطق واسعه من سوريا والعراق
[موسيقى]
زياره الرئيس الفرنسيه
للولايات المتحده قصتنا الثانيه صنفها
الاليزيه بالاستثنائيه فهي ثاني زياره
دوله يقوم بها مكرون لامريكا والاولى له
في عهد نظيره الرئيس
برفقه زوجته بريجيت الى قاعده اندروس
الجويه في واشنطن والتي لا يطؤها الا كبار
الشخصيات وكانت في استقباله نائبه وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
عشاء خاص او بدايه ونشاط مكروه وعشاء خاص
وزوجته اي ان اول لقاء ياخذ طبعا شخصيا
ويوفر لهما الفرصه للبحث في الملفات
الرئيسيه بعيدا عن الشكليات المفروضه جدول
الزياره رصدته لنا ريتا سليمان
من التوتر في العلاقات بين الجانبين بدا
الرئيس والفرنسيه
زياره الرسميه الى الولايات المتحده
تتناول العديد من الملفات ابرزها ازمه
اوكرانيا ومواجهه النفوذ الصيني فضلا عن
قضايا اقتصاديات الرئيس الامريكي جو بيد
ان اعد برنامج حافلا لمكرون يتضمن عشاء
عائليا خاصا كما سيحضى مكروم باستقبال
رسمي في البيت الابيض مع اطلاقي احدى و20
طلقه مدفعيه واستعراض حرس الشرف وزياره
لمقبره ارض الخميس واعد عشان رسميا
الموسعا في البيت الابيض بحضور المئات
الاشخاص وسيعقد الريسان بعد اجتماعهما
مؤتمر صحافيا مشتركا وعلى جدول الاعمال
الرئيس الفرنسي زياره الى الكونغرس يلتقي
في خلالها اعضاء الشيوخ والنواب وتنتهي
زياره الرئيس الفرنسي في مدينه نيويورك
ذات الرمزيه التاريخيه لفرنسا
اذا هي زياره استثنائيه لترميم الصداقه
التي تصدعت منذ تلك اللحظه في سبتمبر
العام الماضي حينما اعلنت امريكا تحالف
اوكوس مع استراليا وبريطانيا ما اثرها غضب
فرنسا التي حرمت من عقد ضخم لبيع غواصات
الى كاميرا
وستبعدت كذلك من الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه
في منطقه المحيطين الهادئ والهندي
الاستراتيجيه مع دول شرق اسيا لمجابهه
النفوذ الصيني المتناميه وايضا لبناء قدره
اقليميه على الصمود امام التهديدات
العابره للحدود لكن الشعره التي قسمت ظهر
العلاقه بينهما يبدو انها كانت تداعيات
الازمه الاوكرانيه التي حتما ستصدر اجنده
اجتماع المكتب البيضاوي سواء فيما يتعلق
بالدعم العسكري او حتى في الشقه التجاري
المختلف عليه نقطه التباين او التباعد
ربما كانت على حد وصف مسؤولينا سياسيين هي
الاستغلال الامريكي الواضح لان قطع
الروسيه عن دول الاتحاد الاوروبي دفعها
للهروله نحو مصادر غاز بديله اهمها امريكا
لكن الاخيره يبدو انها تتاجر بغازها على
حساب الدول الاوروبيه لانها رفعت الاسعار
بوجه القاره العجوز وجعلتها على حد وصفهم
خياليه ولا تصدر من صديق حينها كان مكرون
ناقد الاول او المعاتب الاول لا فرق لانه
بدا وكانه يؤنب امريكا والنرويج في احد
تصريحاته كيف تفعلون ذلك معنا بحق الصداقه
يدوكم بطيخ امريكا
[موسيقى]
اقامها في الاليزي حثهم في خلالها على
البقاء في فرنسا وعدم الانتقال الى امريكا
التي بفعلتها هذه تستقطبهم لارضها ما
سيؤثر سلبا على قطاعات فرنسا في عده مجلات
كالسيارات الكهربائيه والبطاريات والطاقه
النظيفه حتى مكروه اكدال المدعوين الاسبوع
الماضي انه سيزور واشنطن ليدافع عن مصالح
باريس واوروبا ككل في مواجهه قانون خفض
التضخم وبعيدا عن الخلافات سيكون واجبا
مناقشه ما يصب في مصلحه الاوكرانيين اليس
كذلك مثل قرار ميته بتعزيز الوجود العسكري
على ابواب روسيا اضافه لاعلان واشنطن
تعزيزه جنودها في دول البلطيق ليبقى
السؤال هل سى يكتب للتحالف الذي يبدو
متزعزع تاره ومتوحدا تاره اخرى ان يصمد في
وجه الشتاء لمؤازره اوكرانيا
اذا زياره ليست عاديه كما لاحظنا بل انها
تحمل معاني اخرى في الرمزيه والتاريخ
والثقافه لان ماكرون سيخدمها في الثاني من
ديسمبر بعيدا عن العاصمه واشنطن ذاهبا الى
نيويورك التي لم يحالفه النصيب بان يزورها
في عهد الرئيس السابق ترامب ليصبح اول
زعيم فرنسيه يزور هذه المدينه منذ عام
يسير مكرونه اذا على دربي رؤساء فرنسيين
سابقين اذ اتى الى ديارها لاول مره شارلي
جول في عام
1960 ثم
فاليريجسكار واليوم يسجل مكروه نفسه كالت
زعيم
فرنسيجارو ان زياره تهدف الى عرض بصمه
فرنسا الثقافيه والاجتماعيه في الولايات
المتحده لكون يورينز اكبر مدن ولايه
لويزيانا كانت مستعمره فرنسيه سابقا
ويحن اليها الفرنسيون بين الف ليله
والاخرى فهي مازال تفتخر باصولها الفرنسيه
حتى بعد ان قطعت فرنسا العلاقات وبعتها
الى امريكا حتى من يتجول في الشوارع ويحدث
المواطنين سيجد ان عدد منهم يحافظ على
التقاليد الثقافيه لفرنسا في المطاعم في
الماكولات في غيرها وصولا الى الاحتفال
الباستيل وفي عام
1803 عندما انتقلت يو اورينس بشكل دائم
الى الحكم بقي العديد من اسماء الشوارع
فنسيا مثل شوارع بيانفيل وايبارفيل
واحتفاء بذلك وتفكيرا لامريكا بان جزء
منها كان يوما فنسيا
يخطط مكروم بحسب له في جرو للاعلان عن
صندوق لتمويل تعليم الفرنسيه وليس انتهاء
بالمرور شوقا الى الحي الفرنسيه الذي يضجه
بالحياه رغم مبانيه السكنيه الاقدم في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نتابع في
مناقشه هذا الموضوع بمختلف بابعاده همم
التي ناقشناها قبل قليل معنا من واشنطن
دونالد جنس كبير الخبراء في معهد السلام
الاميركيه اهلا بك معنا استاذ دونالدز لو
حددت لنا بدايه اهم نقطه خلاف لا تزال
عالقه ستكون على راس جدول الاعمال مع
السيناريوهات المطروحه للطرق حلها
وافرشي
فرنسا كما تعلمون
من اقدم الحلفاء للولايات المتحده وتجدون
العلم الفرنسيه في كل شارع وانه لشرف كبير
للرئيس بايدن ان يستقبل نظيره الفرنسيه
وبعد ان تم دعوته لعشاء الرسميه فرنسا
والولايات المتحده هم شركه قد لا يتفقون
فيما بينهم احيانا ولكنهم ما يكونن
الاحترام والسيد ماكرون لاعب دورا فاعل في
السياسه الخارجيه الفرنسيه في اوروبا
واسيا والصين وروسيا والشرق الاوسط وهكذا
دولي
بالنسبه لاداره فهي تحترم هذه التحركات
وترغب بان تكون هذه العلاقات متينه رغم
كافه اوجه الخلافات الموجوده بينهما فرنسا
سوف تبقى شريكا وحديثا قويا خاصه عندما
تكون السياسه في حاله من الفوضى المبعثره
فلابد لهذه العلاقه بمع فرنسا ان تبقى
متينه بعد وجوده وتناول عشاء رسمي اعتقد
انه ضرب من دروب الدبلوماسيه الخاصه
بالبيت الابيض نعم هذا في اطار الحلف بين
البلدين ولكن في اطار نقاط الاختلاف
الرئيسيه عن اين نقاط خلافنا رئيسيا نتحدث
والى اي مدى يمكن الاتفاق على بعض الخطوط
العريضه للبداء للبدء في حلها اوروبا
وباريس خاصه منزعجه جدا من موضوع اسعار
النفط والغاز للولايات المتحده يعني شاءت
همم دور فاعل في ذلك فيما يتعلق بالحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا اضافه الى المواضيع
القديمه الجديده
وياك
الجمله من اوجه الخلافات في اسعار الطاقه
في اوروبا باتت في حاله ارتفاعا كبير ولا
يرغب الاوروبيون ان يستمر ان يستمر الامر
على هذا المنوال وكذلك قانون الانتاج تلقى
انتقادات كبيره
والعاليه اقول بصراحه انا
الرئيس الفرنسيه قد يكون امه متفائلا ولا
علي همم يجب علي ان اكون
حذرا في التعبير عن ذلك في مساله الحرب
هذه هي طبيعه الحلفاء وخاصه في مساله
اوكرانيه كما تعلمون ان ان ان
البعض قد تعبر عن ان السيد مكرون قد اطلق
تصريحات غير صحيحه بشان احلال للسلامه في
اوكرانيا لكن الامور تتغيرت بعد ان قدم
كافه المعونات
لمقاومه الروسيه فهذه العلاقه التي تربط
البلدين قد تحمل في طياتها بعض اوجه
الاختلاف لكن المفتاح الاساسي هو التعاون
بين البلدين ومساله اوجه الاختلافات قد
تبقى هي النزاعات بشان الامور التي ذكرتها
مثل قانون تحفيظ
قانون قانون
انكماش الاقتصادي وهذا ما كان قد اخيرا
اثار حفيظه الشعب الاوروبي لكن ينتظر
الرئيس الفرنسي ويرحب به في البيت الابيض
شكرا جزيلا لك دونالدز كبير خبراء في معاد
السلام الامريكي من واشنطن تحياتي اليك
في النهايه اعتقد اننا كدول مختلفه علينا
ان نتحد معا واعتقد ان العمل معا ودعم
بعضنا امر مهم بالاضافه الى دعم اوكرانيا
واي دوله قد تكون حلفاء معها
وبالتاكيد سيكون فصل الشتاء وقتا عصيبا
اعتقد انها ستكون احدى القضايا التي
يناقشها ماكرون الليله مع الرئيس بيض ايضا
لنرى ما اذا كان هناك حل سلمي
اعتقد ان الغربه
سيستمر خلال الشتاء
وقايضات حول تخصيص الاموال وانفاقها فقد
نحتاج الى الاحتفاظ ببعضها في الداخل اكثر
من الخارج هذه قرارات صعبه اعملوا ان يكون
استمرار التحالف ممكنا لكنني لست متاكده
من ذلك
الصحفيه نسران فاروق بعد اعتقالها في
منزلها همم
نتابع ولكن رياضيا ونعود الى خب- الى
خبرنا الاول
الماتش يعني الكروي الهام جدا في تاريخ
السعوديه من الدوحه موفد العربيه ليت
بازاري اهلا بك معنا ليس همم واضح انه لكل
منشد تماما خلفك على غير العادي يعني بعد
مباريات بيكونوا كلهم حواليك تفضل كيف
الجو عندك
الجو صامت الكل مركز مع المباراه يا طاهر
كما رصدت قبل قليل فجميع هنا ينتظر فوز ان
شاء الله فوز المنتخب السعودي في هذه
المباراه والبيت السعودي هنا في الدوحه
يعني ممتلئ هذه الساحه التي نشاهد في عمق
الصوره كما تشاهد لا يوجد حتى مكان للمشي
في وسط هذه الساحه واذا شاهدنا على يسار
الشاشه هناك من من
يجلس على همم على الارض الخضراء
خلينا نسمع صوتهم شويه واذا في حدا حواليك
يعني تحكي معه كمان بيكون مناسب
[تصفيق]
همم اسمه محمد هو من الاردن اوه بشتغل هون
في المطاعم المخصصه في البيت السعودي ولكن
اليوم طالع كانك كسول تركت الطبخ والاكل
من شان شاهد المباراه
يا محمد
الناس كلها مشغوله بالمباراه الوضع كثير
محمص جدا والناس تستنى في نتيجه المباراه
ان شاء الله الفوز السعوديه
طبعا ان شاء الله الله يخليك نعم نعم طاهر
يعني هذه الاجواء اذا اخذنا الكاميرا من
الجهه الاخرى بدون ما نمر قدام المتفرجين
لانه عن جد بصير توتر اذا نسيته
في الشاشه التي امامنا امامنا نشاهد هناك
كثير الذين يقفون حتى ولو على طرف الشاشه
خبير التي تبث المباراه مباشره هنا في
البيت السعودي والذين يحاولون فقط لمح
المباراه او لمح ارضيه الملعب وطريقه لعب
المنتخب السعودي والمنتخب المكسيكي طبعا
ولكن يعني الجميع متحمس وسوف يعني نحاول
الاقتراب قدر الامكان لان همم كما قلت لك
قبل قليل من الصعب ان نكون امام المتفرجين
الذين همم يحاولون طبعا
ممكن نشوف يعني
كيف كيف يعني عدد المتفرجين بجميع الاعمار
يصلون حتى الحاجز الابيض الذي نشاهد هنا
همم هنا في هذه في هذه
الساحه الكبيره وجميع طبعا همم ينظر الى
المباراه ويحاول رصد اقل فرصه لتسجيل هدف
للمنتخب السعودي في ملعب لوسيل هنا في
الدوحه وو مثل ما بتشوف يعني التركيز عميق
عميق جدا في المباراه
يعني بالضبط بالضبط
[ضحك]
سمعت هتاف عجبني كثير طاهر بيقول العب
العب هزي شباك الملعب خلي الخصم يتعب
وبعدين وبعدين في بقولوا يا سعودي جينا من
كل مدينه والفوز باذن الله باذن الله لينا
هذه
عشرات اذا مش مئات المرات كل الله الله
الذي طبعا يبث مباراه السعوديه والمكسيك
شكرا جزيلا ان شاء الله بنرجع اليك مع
فرحتنا النصر بعد قليل في العربيه 360
مصافحه السيسي واردوغان لم تهدم كل
الجدران لائقات مصريه اربعه للمصالحه
تتعلق بليبيا وشرق المتوسط
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
مقتل زعيم داعش الذي بدانا به العربيه
معنا من القاهره البحث في شؤون جماعه
المتطرفه ماهر فرغلي اهلا بك معنا استاذ
ماهر في هذه النشره همم يعني ما تفسيرك او
همم يعني معلوماتك او تحليلك من قراءتك
لما حصل مع ابو الحسن القرشي وكيف تم
اختيار خليفه
بعد التحيه للشتاء بشطار وساده المشاهدين
في قناه العربيه الموقره
المعلومات التي وصلتني من بعض المصادر
الخاصه ان هناك معركه جرت بين الفصائل
السوريه مع تنظيم داعش في
المنطقه المحيطه بمدينه درعا السوريه
وفي اثناء هذه المعركه قتل ابو الحسن
الهاشمي القرشي زعيم تنظيم داعش همم
معلومات التي كانت بحوزتنا اوليه ولم تكن
مؤكده بشركه كامل وهي ان رئيس اللجنه
المفوضه لتنظيم داعش جمعه عواد البدري
شقيق ابو بكر البغدادي ابراهيم عواد
البدري هو من كان يتولى قياده التنظيم تحت
اسم الحركه يا ابو الحسن الهاشمي القرشي
همم
قتل في هذه المعركه الداخليه الزيتيه مع
الفصائل السوريه طبعا هم لديهم تراتبيه في
في توليات القيادات همم واعلنوا عن مقتله
بسرعه نظرا هذا هو عبد الله قرداش يعني
ابو ابراهيم الهاشمي وليس طبعا همم
المعروضه على الشاشه وليس ابو الحسن
الهاشمي ال- ال- الزعيم الذي يسبق همم
جمعه وادي البدري تمام لا هذه هي تعرض على
شاشه صور عامه عن الموضوع يعني مش
بالضروره عن اسماء محدده عن كل الموضوع
بجانب مختلفه نعم
قتلوا كلهم في سوريا يعني ابو بكر
البغدادي في سوريا همم ابراهيم القرشي
المعروض صورته منذ قليل في سوريا الزعيم
الجديد ايضا في سوريا يعني التواجد دائما
في مناطق هي تحرير الشام هناك اتفاقيه شبه
اتفاقيه لحمايه حمايه زعماء داعش في هذه
المنطقه اتفاقيه مع الفصائل السوريه حينما
همم فشلت هذه الاتفاقيه دارت معركه قتل
فيها الزعيم الحالي للتنظيم اهل الحلو
والعقد يعني مجلس الشورى مع لجنه المفوضه
بيجلسه يختاره واحد نسبه قريش وبالمناسبه
وهذا هو السبب في الاعلام مبكرا على عن
مقتل رغم انه لم لم
لم يكن يدري احد ان الزعيم داعش قتل او
حتى الذي قتلوا اعلن عن مقتله لكن فقهيا
لابد من الاعلان عن الزعيم الجديد لكي
تنجح البيعه لبيعه القرش اليكيه يكون
خليفه وفققه الفقه الذاتي لتنظيم ده عشان
مش سامعه هم اعلنوا عن مقتلي وتوليات
الجديده
والمتتاليه يعني الى اي مدى تضعف بحكم
عقيده تفكر والنظام الداخلي اللي داعش الى
اي مدى هذه التغييرات مقتل الزعيم كل مره
وتعيين خليفه يؤثر همم في معنوياته في
اداءه
في خلال 10 شهور قتل زعيم يعني 10 شهور
فتره وجيزه جدا يعني من قبل ابو ابراهيم
هيمي ثم ابو بكر البغدادي اربعه في خلال
عامين هذا في فتره وجيزه جدا جدا هذا
للتنظيم يهتز حركيا يفقد الاتباع والعناصر
الجديده المعنويات يكلف التنظيم البحث عن
زعيم جديد خاصه انهم يشترطوا عليا ان يكون
من نسل قريشي من نسل هاشمي هذا هذا شيء
صعب جدا وهذا ينظر داخل هذا التنظيم ومن
ثم هذا يسبب مشكله حقيقيه في البيعه يسبب
مشكله حقيقيه في الانقسامات الداخليه
للتنظيم نحن نعلم ان تنظيم داعش يعني
اربعه فروع داخليه يعني هو ليس فرع واحد
فرع ابو محمد الفرقان فرع همم تركي بن علي
وكلهم قتلوا بالمناسبه فرع ابو جعفر حطاب
التونسي ابو جعفر حطاب هو كلهم مختلفين
فكريا والفرع الاخير هو فرع كان همم فرع
ابو بكر البغدادي وكلهم مختلفين فكريا حول
ما يسمى مساله العذر بالجهل والتطبيقها
على ساكنه دوله يعني هل تعمم ام لا تعمم
وهل يكفرون جميعا ام لا ومن ثم تحدث
خلافات مع مقتل الزعيم هل هو من هذا الطرف
هل هذا من هذا الفريق ام من هذه الفريق
اعتقد ستحدث صراعات داخل التنظيم بسبب هذه
التوليه شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه الايضاحات
والمعلومات من القاهره البحث في سوء جماعه
متطرفه
[موسيقى]
روسيا بدات حربا في اوكرانيا توقعتها
سريعه وانها سترضع حلف شمال الاطلسي
للابتعاد عن الحدود الروسيه وهذا لم يحدث
روسيا تتخذ موقفا
في اوروبا لذلك قامت في ديسمبر الماضي
بنشر مسوده اتفاقيات بينها والولايات
المتحده
والتي تنص على الالتزام بعدم توسع الناتو
شرقا انطلقت حرب اوكرانيا مجاوره لروسيا
مسيعيها للانضمام كي لا تقع في مازق
المشابه لاوكرانيا وفيما الماضي تقدمت
السويد وفنلندا دولتان المحيودتان اصلا
بطلب رسمي للانضمام للحلف حينها اعتبر
رئيس روسي
دنفيتين لا يهدد موسكو بشكل مباشر لكنه
شدد على ان اي توسع في البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه للنيتو من شانه ان يؤدي الى رد
من الكرملين توقعوا خبراء روسبال توقعوا
انه منمله الاجراءات الممكنه ان تنشر
روسيا مجموعه دفاع صاروخي وجوي جديده في
الشمال الغربي وعسكرت منطقه جراد
وبيلاروسيا وتعزيز اساطير والشمال
[موسيقى]
انضمامه فنلندا والسويد الى الناتو سيزيده
مساحه حدود الحلف مع روسيا بالف 1300 كيلو
متر تمثل طول الحدود بين البلدين مصدر قلق
فنلندا ياتي من التاريخ القديم والمعاصر
ففي نوفمبر من عام
1939 اصدر الرئيس السوفياتي جوزيف ستالين
اوامره باعلان الحرب على فنلندا كان
السوفيات وقتها يعتبرون ان فنلندا الخاسر
الرخوه التي من الممكن ان تكون منصه
لاستهداف في بلادهم وسط الصراع مع المانيا
انذاك عرفت تلك الحرب بحرب الشتاء واستمرت
10 اشهر وانتهت بمعاهده موسكو للسلام في
الثالث عشر من مارس من عام 1940 وفي
ايامنا الحاليه تتخوف فنلندا كذلك تتخوف
من ان يعيد سيناريو حرب الشتاء نفسه
وتقدمت بطلب الانضمام للنيته الذي مازال
معلقه ايضا عرضت فنلندا على اوكرانيا
تدريب جنودها استعدادا لحرب الشتاء
المتوقعات قريبا
[موسيقى]
من العاصمه نيوزلانديه برزت تصريحات ادلت
بها رئيسه الوزراء الفلنديه سنه مارين
خلال مؤتمرها مع نظيرتها جسددا مارين طلبت
بتقديم المزيد من الاسلحه والدعم
لاوكرانيا لضمان انتصارها في حرب هذا
الدروسيا اضافت رئيسه الوزراء الفنلنديه
ان الدول بحاجه لاظهار القوه الصلبه عندما
يتعلق الامر باوكرانيا التي تحتاج بحسب
مرين للاسلحه والدعم المالي والانساني كما
طلبت مريم دول الغربيه بالتشديد العقوبات
على روسيا بسبب تاثير الحرب الذي يطال
الجميع كالمدانيين في اوكرانيا اضافه
لجميع الشعوب العالم جراء ارتفاع اسعار
الطاقه
[موسيقى]
الحرب في اوكرانيا تبدو ملموسه جدا من
وجهه نظر فنلندا لاننا نتقسم حدودا طويله
مع روسيا كنا سابقا في حاله حرب مع روسيا
لذا فالوضع ملموس جدا للشعب الفنلندي
اوكرانيا بحاجه للدعم وعلينا التاكد من
انتصارهم في الحرب فهم بحاجه الى المزيد
من الاسلحه ارسلنا سابقا 10 دفعه من
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا ونحتاج ايضا للتاكد
من ان العقوبات اصعب واقصى ضد روسيا
قال وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شوشو ان
الدولتين احرزتا بعد التقدم في الاستجابه
لمخاوف انقر الامنيه بعد اجتماع مع نظيره
من فنلندا
ولم توافق تركيا على طلب الانضمام لان
انقرهم بتجاهل التهديدات التي تتعرض لها
تركيا من قبل المسلحين الاكراد والجماعه
الاخرى التي تعتبرها ارها حتى الان صادق
الثمانيه وعشرون دوله من دول الناتو 30
على طلبي الانضمام بينما لم يصادق
البرلمان التركي كذلك نظيره المجاري
الهنجاري واوضح وزير الخارجيه التركيه ان
السويد وفنلندا بحاجه لاقناع الشعب التركي
والبرلمان التركي من جانبه قال وزير
الخارجيه السويدي ان المحادثات مع تركيا
احرزت بعض التقدم باتجاه موافقه تركيا على
انضمام السويد وفنلندا
[موسيقى]
وتركيا وشعارت بعد الاجتماع بوجود تقدم في
هذا الاتجاه نحن نتحرك قدما في تنفيذ
مذكره ثلاثيه تم توقيعها في مدريد ويتم
القيام بذلك على عده مستويات واخطط قريبا
لرحله الى تركيا للقاء زميلي مولود شاهوش
اوغلو في القاره
مراسلنا في اسطنبول
يطلعون الان على الجانب من المطالب
التركيه وماذا تبقى من دوني تنفيذ
يتوجب على فنلندا والسويد تقديم المزيد
بانقره حتى تعطي ضوءا اخضر لدخولهم الناتو
هذا ما اكده وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود
شاويش اوغلو بعد لقاء مع وزراء خارجيه
البلدين في بخارست على هامش اجتماع لحلف
شمال الاطلسي الوزير التركي ذكر بالتحديد
تسليما فنلندا والسويد لمطلوبين للحكومه
التركيه مرحبا في الوقت ذاته بالتزام
الحكومتين بما قال انها الاليه الجديده
لمكافحه الارهاب اذا انقر ما زالت تريد
المزيد من هيلسنكي
الاتراك لا يريدون فقط تصنيف حزب العمال
الكردستاني كتنظيم الارهابي في هاتين
الدولتين بل تسليما المطلوبين وتجميد اصول
بعد التنظيمات التي تصنفها انقر
بالارهابيه ايضا تسعى تركيا في مفاوضاتها
مع الدولتين ومع الغرب الى رفع حظر صادرات
السلاح عنها ايضا تسعى تركيا في مفاوضاتها
مع الدولتين الغرب الى رفع حظر صادرات
السلاح عنها ورغم ان معظم القضايا يمكن
حلها لكن القضيه العالقه الابرز ستبقى
تسليم المطلوبين
اذا ناقشنا قبل قليل عرضا قدمته فنلندا
لاوكرانيا لتدريب قواتها على حرب الشتاء
لكن هناك او لكنه هناك حربا يخوضها
الاوكرانيون بمفردهم على ارضهم حرب ضد
الزائر الابيض الذي وان كان موضع ترحيب
على الدوام الا انه في هذا العام تحديدا
غير مرحبا به حذيفه عادل رصد لنا طبيعه
هذه الحرب
تساقط كثيف للثلوج في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كيف في الوقت الذي ما زال 25 بالمئه من
سكان المدينه دون كهرباء وتعمل سلطات
المدينه لاستعاده التيار واستقرار جدول
القطع الكهربائي على ان لا يتجاوز عدد
ساعات الانقطاع خمسه ساعات في اليوم
وسنستعيد جولي بولو محافظه تاريخ
وكل شيء سيكون بخير فهذه اوكرانيا
باي حال من الاحوال سوف نتعامل مع كل
الظروف ولن ننكسر
يعملون بالفعل على ازاله الثلوج من
الطرقات في الوقت الحالي تعمل مئه وسته
وعشرون وحده من المعدات واكثر من 300
متخصصه من هيئه صيانه الطرق ويشاركه في
الحمله اكثر من 1000 عامل من الشركات
متعاقده مع الدوله
مدير عام الشيخ شنيك بريشوف انا اعمل عليه
ازاله الثلوج الثلج يتساقط بطبيعه الحال
في هذا التوقيت ونحن نعمل على ازالتها
ونظافه الشوارع
وفقا للتوقعات ستزداد كثافه تساقط الثلوج
والصقيع في المدينه كما ستنخفض درجه
الحراره الى درجتين مئويتين تنصرف خلال
انهار وسالب 50 درجات مئويه في الليل لذلك
تحث السلطات المواطنين على الامتناع عن
السفر في سياراتهم الخاصه كما يطلب من
السائقين توخي الحذر على الطريق واذا امكن
عدم قياده السياره اثناء تساقط الثلوج اذا
فعادل العربي العربيه كيف
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا اليونسكو تحذر اطفال
العالم في خطر من يملاون عقولهم عزفوا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اذا معلومات جديده من
بيان عسكري امريكي تنقل عنه رويترز ويتحدث
عن ان العمليه التي قادت الى قتل زعيم
تنظيم داعش همم كانت كما بها عناصر الجيش
السوري الحر في درعا تحديدا في منتصف
اكتوبر وهذه المعلومات كان نقلها لنا في
خلال العربيه 360 في بدايتها ضيفنا من
القاهره ماهر فرغلي همم المتحدث يعني
المتخصص في شؤون الجماعات المتطرفه همم
وتحدث عن ان ذلك تم في درعا فعلا بناء على
معلوماته وهمم من الفصائل السوريه اذا هذا
اخر ما يصدر عن البيان للجيش الامريكي
العمليه نفذها الجيش السوري الحر في درعا
بسوريا في منتصف اكتوبر
لاحت في افقي العلاقات التركيه مع مصر مع
تصدر مصافحه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان لنظيره المصريه عبد الفتاح السيسي
كانت مصافحه على شفت تحت كاس العالم في
قطر في ال 20 من نوفمبر لكنها وصفت
بالتاريخيه ايضا صوره فتحت بابا كان قد
اوصت ربما بين البلدين ما يعني ان تطبيع
العلاقات او ربما تصحيحها ذات يلوح في
المدى القريب جمله تصريحات تركيه لا تبعد
عن كونها مؤشرات تقارب واضحه وصريحه
اردوغان قال ان عمليه بناء العلاقه مع مصر
ستبدا باجتماع وزراء من البلدين وان
المحادثات ستتطور انطلاقا من ذلك وزير
الخارجيه التركي مولود شاويش اوغلو ايضا
اشار الى ان الدولتين ستانفان العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه باكملها وان كل منهما سيعيد
تعيين السفراء في الاشهر المقبله حتى
المتحدث باسم الرئاسه التركيه ابراهيم
كالين ذهب الى ابعد من ذلك او الى ابعاد
اكبر بالاحرى موضحا ان هناك احتمالا لعقد
قمه تركيه مصريه بين الرئيسين مضيفا ان
هذا الامر يستلزم تنفيذ كثيرا ان
التحضيرات وتجهيز الاسس وخلال ثلاثه او
اربعه اشهر سنحدد خطواتنا لكن مصر التزمت
الصمت ولم تدخل سباق التصريحات حول هذه
العلاقه بحسب مراقبين محللين قالوا ان
القاهره تريد افعالا لا اقوال ما يعني ان
مصر تفضل اتباع النهج المتدرج المبني على
بنود محدده يحددها كبار المسؤول
علشان يتم الاصلاح بين مصر وتركيا ان هي
هتقف جنب مصر
وتقف جنب امن مصر وتساعد مصر على مقاومه
الارهاب والله تركيه في الظاهر اللي انا
شايفه من حوالي سنه تقريبا بتحاول تتودد
لمصر علشان خاطر اا مصلحتها فقط لا غير
تسليم الهاربين خارج مصر المطلوبين همم
المسابقه القضائيه همم لازم يسلمه مبدئيا
وبعد كده نتكلم في اي احوال ثانيه خطوه
كويسه ان هم
حصل مقابله بينهم وهي المفروض
تصلح العلاقات بين همم وكل العلاقات دول
المصريه على اعلى مستوى وممنوع ان تركيا
تتدخل في الشؤون الداخليه لمصر وتكون
علاقته جاريه اقتصاديه المفروض يبقى في
تعاون امني بحيث ان هم همم احنا نسلمهم
المطلوبين اللي عندنا عليهم وهم يسلمونا
المطلوبين ويبقى في تعاون اقتصادي يساعد
بعض في الاقتصاد نظام التركي الحالي هو
يعمل بالرجماتيه كحه يعني
فهو على حسب مصلحته هيتم همم
السياسيه معروفه ايه اللي مطلوب اعتقد
يعني همم الاداره التركيه عارفه ما يغضب
مصر وما يسعدها ما يسعدها هو التوافق في
الرئه التوافق في الرؤى المصريه التركيه
اذا تم محددات تريدها مصر قبل ان تخطوها
في هذه العلاقه تدريجيا عنوانها رفض رباعي
بحسب مراقبين الاول لا يمكن للقاهره
للقبول باستمرار المرتزقه والقوات
الاجنبيه على الاراضي الليبيه على اعتبار
ان ذلك يعد مساسا بالامن القومي المصري
اللا الثانيه لا يمكن القبول بشرعيه
الاتفاقيات التي وقعتها حكومات ليبيه
سابقه او منتهيه الولايه مع الجانب التركي
وتسمح باجراءات بعيده المدى دون توافق
ليبيا كامل بشانها اما الثالثه فلا عوده
عن اتفاقيات ترسيم الحدود البحريه التي
وقعتها مصر مع كل من اليونان وقبرص
انطلاقا من كونها بحد نظرهم مصدق عليها
وتتفق مع مبادئ القانون الدولي واتفاقيه
الامم المتحده لقانون البحار عام 82
اخر ولائات المصريه تلك انها لا تقبل
المسافه بامن واستقرار وسياده كل من
اليونان وقبرص وان التقارب مع انقره لن
يكون على حساب العلاقات المتميزه مع اثينا
ونيقوسيا يشير الباحثون الى ان الوضع
الاقتصاديه في تركيا ومصر قد يدفع البلدين
الى اعطاء الاولويه للملف التجاري الذي
يعد اكثر سهوله في تحقيق قدر من التوافق
يمكن البناء عليه بعد ذلك بهدف التوصل الى
تنسيقات اهم سياسيا وامنيا
نحب الشعب المصري بيننا روابط تعود الى
العهد العثماني حتى بعد ذلك بقينا مرتبطين
ببعضنا هل هذا صحيح نعم كان هناك تباعد
بين الشعبين لان العلاقات السياسيه كانت
سيئه
العلاقات ونستطيع ايضا القيام بالتبادل
التجاري وتسويه الوضع الاقتصادي والتبادل
الاقتصادرات لماذا نبرم اتفاقيات مع دول
بعيده عنك الولايات المتحده وغيرها
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للعلاقات التركيه المصريه بدلا من
العلاقات مع الولايات المتحده وروسيا
برايي علاقتنا مع دول الجوار يجب ان تكون
افضل من علاقتنا مع الدول البعيده
مهمه من الناحيه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه
كشعبين لدينا روابط مشتركه من الناحيه
الدينيه تركيا
حدث شيء غير متوقع وهو لقاء الرئيسين
السيسي واردوغان
يعني
معنى من القاهره عصافير الدكتور محمد
حجازي مساعد وزير الخارجيه الاسبق اهلا
بكم معنا سعد السفير في العربيه التي 260
هل عدم وجود ذكر لموضوع الاخوان بشكل
اساسي في اللائقات الحاليه التي يتم
الحديث عنها يعني بانه هذا الموضوع استكمل
انجز تعتبر القاهره بانه تم قامت تركيا
بما يجب عليها ان تقوم به في هذا الشق
تحديدا
والخطوه الايجابيه التي وقعت في الدوحه
الرئيسه هو امر هام جدا وضروره فيما يتعلق
بالصوص التي تعلمها التركيه همم فيما يخص
الملفات العالقه التي نامل همم ان يتبناها
الجانب التركي وينفذها قبل ان نتحدث عن
استكمال كافه جوانب العلاقات من بينها هذا
الملف واعتقد ان التدخل في الشان الداخلي
نتفق جميعا انه مرفوض ان اسس عوده
العلاقات هو هذا الملف مع امن طبعا
واستقرار منطقه المتوسط والملف الليبي
ايضا من الملفات الهامه مصر ستعطي هذه
الخطوه الايجابيه التي حدثت في الدوحه
ومصافحه الرئيسين كل ما يلزمها من بوادر
طيبه من جانبنا مصر دوله تحترم قواعد
القانون الدولي لا تتدخل في الشان الداخلي
التركي تامل في تحقيق قدر من التوافق يسمح
باطلاق طاقات المنطقه الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه خاصه طاقات الغاز في شرق
المتوسط التي يستلذبها تستلزم استقرار
اقليمي مصر حريصه عليه تركيا دوله هامه هو
مؤثره في محيطها الاقليمي وكذلك مصر
الروابط الشعبيه تاريخيه وعميقه همم
الاقتصاد الوطني في البلدين المرشح
للتلاقي وتحقيق مكاسب اكثر
كبدايه بعد المصافحه اكثر للملفات الاخرى
المتوسط ليبيا
اظن هذه البادره الطيبه وعلى مستوى القمه
ستتيح الفرصه لمزيد من التشاور لاستكمال
شروط عوده العلاقات الطيبه الماموله بين
الجانبين هو خبر يقين هان لامن واستقرار
المنطقه الكل يسعى من اجل الاستفاده من
ثروات المتوسطه بالشكل الذي يسمح للملاذين
بالتحقيق مكاسب ولكن دون الاكتئاب ودون
التدخل في الشتاء الداخلي باي باي حتى مصر
طلباتها متعلقه ايضا باليونان وقبرص
وليبيا وليس فقط بالوضع الداخلي بالتالي
اا ال- باعتقادك وبتقدك همم الاصعب
والاخطر في طبيعه الخلافات المتبقيه همم
الملف الليبي همم او شكل المتوسط ككل بما
فيه اليونان قبرص
بشكل كبير حتى ان الرئيس اردوغان دعا مصر
للاستخدام اتصالاتها للتحقيق التوافق مع
الدول التي يراها هو في من اجل تحقيق
الامن والاستقرار والسلامه في المنطقه حتى
يتم الاستفاده من الثروات الموجوده في شرق
المتوسط لابد من تحقيق استقرار اقليم هذا
هو مكانه دائما مصر تنادي به وتمشي
الاطراف جميعا للالتفاف حوله ان اعتقد ان
الدور المصري الايجابي والمتفاعل مع اي
بادره طيبه تاتي من الجانب التركي ستقود
حتما لمزيد من الاستقرار والتواصل بين
الاطراف هل توافق على يعني بدايه همم
يعني بعض القصص التي يتحدثن فيها عن
الموضوع نصف انفراجه
والله نحنا نعمل ان تكون افرجها كامله
ولكن كيف تحقق الانفراجه الكامله لابد من
التحضير الجيد ولابد من وفاء الاطراف
بتاعداتها وانا اعتقد ان لدينا مجال طيبا
مدامه النوايا حسنه وما دامت الاراده
السياسيه متوفره شكرا دكتور محمد حجازي
مساعد وزير الخارجيه الاسبق تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من باكستان
يريد ان يشعره بالامان رغم انه لم يتبقى
في ملابسه مساحه لم تلوثها الدماء يحاول
الاب ان يذهب من عيني طفله هذا الشعور
بالفزع والدهون لكنه مهما حاول لن يستطيع
ان يفسر له لماذا تستهدف طالبان دوريه
شرطه ترافق حمله للتطعيم ضد شلل الاطفال
لن يستطيع ان يشرح له كيف تضرب طالبان
التي تقول انها تدافع عن الدين ضربه واحده
تحرم فيها اطفال من الحياه واخريننا من
العلاج
هكذا نصل الى ختام العربيه 360 ولكن اخبار
الساعه لا تنقطع يتابع فيها صهيب شراير
الان ومعه برنامجه اخبار ساعه صهيب مساء
الخير الكلمه الاولى للمباراه اليوم اكيد
وخبر الساعه ان سيكون خلال الاخبار الساعه
سيكون الشوط الثاني انت كان لديك الشوط
الاول نتيجه حتى الان صفر مقابل صفر طبعا
في انتظار طبعا وتمنياتنا بفوز الاخضر
السعودي يا رب بعد قليل في الشوط الثاني
فقط